approche que j'observe c'est que le
maire de Dijon est à la peine
bien évidemment qu'il embalotage
puisqu'il a 38% malgré malgré l'effet de
la crise sanitaire qui profite à tous
les mers sortants il dit qu'à 38%, alors
il était quand même parce que c'est
exactement ce que je viens de dire et
des mères sortants qui n'en profite pas
comme vous parliez de dormir sortant à
%, alors qu'il était quand même à 44 %
en 2014 au premier majorité divisée une
majorité sortante divisée et les
écologistes le problème aujourd'hui
c'est que le maire sortant n'est plus le
rassembleur mais est-ce qu'on peut vous
est-ce qu'on peut vous renvoyer que vous
faites le plus faible score de la droite
à Dijon dans l'histoire ou municipale
bah écoutez on a fait 20 on fait 20% sur
cette élection et très clairement
aujourd'hui le deuxième tour le deuxième
tour est complètement ouvert si jamais
il a lieu dimanche prochain alors je
vous propose donc